>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Mary Jane Deeb: [Inaudible]
the chief of the African
and Middle East Division and I'm
delighted to be reading today
to celebrate Jewish
American heritage month.
And we have been doing this
every year and each section
of the division has done --
has partnered with the
Jewish Genealogy Society
of Greater Washington.
So [inaudible] back here
and I met Mary Jane again
who was part of the society.
And we had [inaudible]
Mary Jane's.
The African Middle East
Division, as you know,
has [inaudible] section
which connects [inaudible]
from all over the world.
[Inaudible] and [inaudible]
We also have an African section.
I think that all the
countries of Africa
in the [inaudible] section that
goes from Morocco to Afghanistan
to Central Asia and
the Caucasus.
So we do collect widely and
hopefully deeply as well,
and but the most important
is our specialists.
And our specialists are scholars
themselves who know the world,
who know the country, who have
wide network among scholars
like yourselves, and we
invite them to join us here
in the library because it is
from the scholars that we learn
so much about what we hold.
In other words, it's a circle.
You teach us, and we will
[inaudible] the books
that inform you.
So it's [inaudible].
And today we have one of
the professor who introduce
by Ms. Horowitz and
[inaudible] but I just wanted
to read a few things that
was said about the book,
Roads Taken: Jewish Peddlers
and their American Journey.
And I was searching it
and I found one review.
First of all, it's about the
book, which was a finalist
in the 2015 National Jewish
Book award in the category
of American Jewish Studies.
And it was this time that this
landmark study permanently
changed our perceptions of
the modern Jewish experience
and Jewish social
and economic history.
It is Jonathan Karp, author of
The Politics of Jewish Commerce,
Economic Thought
and Emancipation in
Europe, 1638-1848.
So as this [inaudible] book
and this marvelous account
of [inaudible] that
was [inaudible] fiction
in [inaudible] Hasia Diner
imaginatively paces down some
of the dusty roads in this
Jewish peddler's [inaudible].
She shows how work, pressure,
and religious belief
are deeply entwined.
That was Walter Friedman,
author of Birth of a Salesman.
And a third one is
[inaudible] Robin Cohen
from Oxford University
who describes the book
as this intensely
researched book
about the underside
Jewish migration
which provides a
[inaudible] account
of how [inaudible] intervention
[inaudible] influence
your societies.
[Inaudible] is [inaudible].
So now to introduce Hasia
Diner, Professor Diner,
is our own Ms. Horowitz.
>> Sharon Horowitz: Okay.
Thank you, Mary Jane.
Let me add my welcome
to everyone.
Yes. I'll try.
On behalf of the
Jewish Genealogy Society
of Greater Washington
and the Hebraic section,
I want to thank you all for
coming to today's program
in celebration of Jewish
American Heritage Month.
The Hebraic section marked
its beginning in 1912
with the receipt of
10,000 Hebrew books
and pamphlets whose purchase
was made possible by a gift
from New York philanthropist
Jacob Schiff.
From those humble beginnings,
our collections have grown
to around 250,000 items in
Hebrew, Yiddish, Ladino, Judeo,
Persian and other
Hebraic script languages.
The Hebraic section also
includes an important collection
of books in Ge'ez, Amharic
and Tigrinya, the languages
of Ethiopia past and present.
Two of our missions
in this division are
to publicize our collections
and to bring people
into the library.
One way we accomplish
this second goal is
by holding lectures
and by having programs
such as the one we are
hosting here today.
Before I introduce today's
speaker, it is my pleasure
to call upon Ms. Sheila Wexler,
President of the
Jewish Genealogy Society
of Greater Washington and one
of today's program's cosponsors,
to say a few words
about the society.
[ Applause ]
>> Sheila Wexler: Thank you
and this is a pleasure for us
to be here today and to
sponsor our wonderful speaker.
The Jewish Genealogy Society of
Greater Washington was created
about 37 years ago,
a little over that,
and the purpose was the interest
in tracing your family tree.
And as time went on, we found
out that our mission
was more than that.
It was education.
We wanted people to understand
how research was done,
what was the purpose
of doing genealogy,
and then to go beyond
that, and that was
to understand our families
and those that made
up our ancestral peoples.
Where they came from, how
they lived, what they did
in the United States, and
how they existed before they
got here.
So it was more than just
getting a name and a date.
And I think we've been
successful with that.
While the focus still
remains on, you know,
finding your ancestors and
building that family tree,
we've gone beyond that.
And with DNA testing, we're
finding even more people
who are interested in genealogy.
So we're winding up with
more than Jewish members,
that is those who
identify as Jewish today.
We're winding up with
people from other cultures
who are saying, "I don't
understand why this is showing
up in my DNA."
I had one lady who
came up to me and said,
"I don't understand what
this Iberian thing is."
She's never been [inaudible]
the American Revolution.
And I said, "Hmm.
Iberian. You know, possibly
you've got a Sephardim,
a Jewish person from
Spain, in your background."
And she just -- then she
proceeded to tell me the story
about a great-great-great
grandmother who,
on her death bed, started
speaking another language.
So I think you may have
somebody spoke [inaudible].
And she walked away
just shaking her head.
I had a letter from someone
from a university the other day
who was interested in our group.
She has Jamaican background
and said, "Jamaican Jewish?
Is that possible?"
It is. So, you know, we're
finding more and more people
who are interested
because of the DNA.
So we welcome everybody
to come to our meetings.
Become members.
We help each other learn.
And so it isn't just pick
up the book and you're going
to find your names in there.
It's understand what your
family did when they got here,
and that's what we're so happy
to have Hasia Diner
[inaudible] here with us today.
[ Applause ]
>> Sharon Horowitz: Thank
you very much, Ms. Wexler.
And now a word about
our speaker.
Hasia Diner is the Paul S.
and Sylvia Steinberg Professor
of American Jewish History
at New York University
with the joint appointment
in the Departments of History
and the Skirball Department
of Hebrew and Judaic Studies.
She's also the director
of the Goren Center
for American Jewish History.
Professor Diner is a
specialist in immigration
and ethnic history,
American Jewish history
and the history of
American women.
She has published a great
deal on these topics
and has lectured widely.
We are indeed fortunate to
have her with us here today.
Two items of business
before we begin.
Professor Diner's book
will be available for sale
and that she will be
signing in the back.
And this event is
being videotaped
for subsequent broadcasting.
There will be a formal
question and answer period
after the lecture, at which
the audience is encouraged
to ask questions
and offer comments.
But please be advised that your
voice and image may be recorded
and later broadcast
as part of this event.
By participating in the
question and answer period,
you are consenting to the
library's possible reproduction
and transmission
of your remarks.
And now please join me in
welcoming Professor Hasia Diner.
[ Applause ]
>> Hasia Diner: Okay.
Let me get myself situated here.
Okay. Just take a second.
Okay great.
Well, so I want to
thank [inaudible]
and the Jewish Genealogical
Society
for inviting me to this talk.
Okay. I want to thank the
Jewish Genealogical Society
for inviting me and
-- how about that?
Is that better?
Okay. Then let's see what I'm
going to do with my notes.
Okay. I should be fine.
Okay. Thank you.
Let me just begin very
quickly by saying this is a bit
of a homecoming for me
because I began my career
as a graduate student sitting
in the reading room for months
on end and then in the Hebraica
room working on my dissertation
and on a number of
subsequent projects.
And there was a time in
which I'd say the Library
of Congress was my
home away from home.
And it was a tremendous
privilege for me,
as a both young and not so
young scholar to have on the --
a tremendous riches,
unimaginable riches
of this constitution
at my command.
So I thank the library
for making my career.
So let me begin.
Israel Abrams, a scholar at
Cambridge University writing
in the 1890s, like many
other Jewish intellectuals
of his time, saw in the study of
history a way to defend the Jews
against scurrilous attacks.
In 1896 in his probably
most famous book,
Jewish Life in the Middle
Ages, in a chapter on trades
and occupations, he directly
challenged the French writer
[inaudible] who the year
before in his book had asserted
that Jews were cowards.
You know, there's
an air quote there.
They were cowards
because they, quote,
"shunned arduous physical
undertakings and were averse
to dangerous occupations."
Abrams countered this
directly, and in his words,
the Jewish peddler of recent
centuries was no coward.
Had he lacked courage, he
must have remained at home.
We're going to use Abrams
words as a way to --
as a point of entry to thinking
about the historic significant
of peddling and its connection
to the transformative phenomenon
of Jewish migrations
in the modern period.
Going out on the road laden
with a jumble of goods,
sometimes specializing in
a particular type of wear,
was a profound binding
and nearly universal
Jewish experience in the --
what we now, as historians,
call the long 19th century,
starting in the late
18th century
and going into the 1920s.
Not that all Jews peddled,
but rather so many did
in the modern history
of the Jewish people
that it provided the
central pivotal --
that it played a
central pivotal role
in shaping new Jewish
communities.
Jewish migrations
out of familiar
but economically declining
regions to new lands wide open
for settlement and
business, opened up because
of colonial expansion and
the spread of capitalism,
made it possible for Jewish
peddlers to take to the road.
Peddlers very ordinary
prosaic, peripatetic figures,
who unfortunately left
us very little in the way
of a paper trail,
served as the juggernauts
for the Jewish migration,
Jewish migrations.
Their experiences on the
road as the human engines
that drove the massive Jewish
population shift, which brought
over four-and-a-half
million Jews out of central
and eastern Europe as well
as the Ottoman Empire,
to new lands, deserves to be
thought of in historical --
in a historical context.
Now, before I go on, I want
to make three points that --
just to serve as
an introduction.
First, who was a peddler?
And probably if I asked how
many -- in fact, let me do that.
How many people here
had peddlers
in their family background?
Okay. So it's really
common, and the older we are,
the more likely that
we had a grandfather,
a great grandfather, an uncle,
a great uncle who did this.
I'm going to be looking
at, and in the book,
I look at those men, and these
are all men, and ironically
for me, as somebody who defines
herself as a women's historian,
I ended up writing
a book about men,
although women play a very
important role in this story.
And you'll see this
very shortly.
The men who I'm looking at were
peddlers who were on the road,
who on Sunday morning or Monday
morning, slung their pack
on their backs or got up
in a wagon behind a horse,
an ox, a mule, and went out.
And they didn't return to Jewish
settlement, be it their homes
or boarding house or some
other place of residence
in a Jewish community,
until Friday.
So they were on the
road all week.
And so as such, I am not dealing
with urban peddlers, okay?
The men and women who hawk
their wares in the city streets
but in the evening went
back to their own homes,
their own communities.
They had an amazing history
also all over the world
and their story needs to be
examined, but I didn't do that.
So urban peddlers
are not my subject.
Secondly, I want to note that
Jews were not the only peddlers
in America or in the
many other places
that I'm going to mention.
In the context of U.S.
history, in the early republic,
there was the stock figure
of the Yankee peddler.
Young men from declining
New England towns who fanned
out to Western Massachusetts,
to upstate New York,
to the south, to the Midwest.
And notably, all the terrible
things that were later on said
about Jewish peddlers
were exactly what was said
about Yankee peddlers, okay?
So it's maybe their
peddling that caused the ire
of some people around them and
not if they were Jewish or not.
Okay. So there was
the Yankee peddler.
There were German
immigrants who peddled.
There were some Irish
The only other group,
in which for the, again,
this long 19th century,
whose migration we could say
was shaped by peddling or Arabs.
Okay. And these were
primarily young men coming
from what was then referred
to as Syria, Lebanon.
So these were primarily
Christian Lebanese who went
to some of the same places
the Jewish peddlers went to.
And they, like the
Jewish peddlers,
functioned in a migration
process
in which peddling was literally
the engine that drove migration.
And their story also
needs to be told,
and some good historian will
make some nice comparisons
to find either similarities
or differences
between Arab peddling
and Jewish peddling.
Again, I didn't do that
but somebody who has access
to the languages of the Lebanese
peddlers surely should do that.
Okay. And then finally which
will get me into the heart
of my talk, Jewish
peddling was not new
in the long 19th century.
Jews had been peddling
for centuries back
to the middle ages, and the
existence of Jews on the road
in all over Europe as well
as in the Ottoman Empire,
was a fixture of Jewish
history well before my period
and their story also
deserves to be written about.
But I was interested in the way
in which peddling shaped
the Jewish migration
out of their old world into
their new -- the new one.
And the way in which starting
in the late 18th century,
peddling provided the startup by
which Jews discovered a number
of new worlds with peddling
linking their movement
out to some place -- from
some places and into others.
So let me say something
about the places they left.
So we could say on the one
hand, Jewish men left all
of the European continent,
from Alsace in the west,
all the way through
to the Ukraine.
Young Jewish men seeking
to leave their homes picked
up the idea of peddling.
Some places sent a much
larger percentage of peddlers
out than others, and I
could tell you the numbers
are elusive.
Okay. We -- you may be
in the question [inaudible] I'll
tell you [inaudible] I'll talk
about why it's very
hard to know how many.
But places like Bavaria was a
very large sender of peddlers
as was Romania, Posen --
that is that part of --
perhaps I don't need to tell the
genealogists where Posen was.
That is that part of Poland
that was sucked into Prussia.
Lithuania was probably
the largest sender
of Jewish peddlers on the
European continent, okay?
And the stock figure
of the Lithuanian
Jewish peddler is a kind
of universal new
world phenomenon.
So they left every place.
And all of these
places were spots
and then also the
Ottoman Empire and again
with particular communities
sending larger
or smaller numbers of
young men out as peddlers.
They went to nearly every
place in the new world.
Okay. Now I'm going to
distinguish two kinds
of new worlds for
the Jewish peddlers.
So on the one hand,
they went to places
that we would not
ordinarily think of as, quote,
the new world, because
they were still in Europe.
But they were places that were
experiencing the expansion
of capitalism and in
which ordinary people now
had cash to buy things.
So the migration of Jews out
of Poland, parts of Bavaria,
to the British Isles, okay?
Not only to England and
the English countryside.
To Wales, Scotland, Ireland,
okay, were fostered by peddling.
So these are places that
are actually also sending
out immigrants, okay?
Jewish peddlers from Lithuania
are also showing up in Sweden
in the 1860s and 1870s.
And what makes the
British Isles and Sweden,
what holds them together
vis-a-vis Jewish history,
and why I think -- I
consider them new worlds,
is that these are places
that had had no substantial
Jewish presence before.
So the young Jewish --
Lithuanian Jewish men from
the province of Kovno,
who show up in Ireland, okay,
starting in the 1870s and 1880s,
went to a place where there
had never been Jews before.
So to them, as Jews,
it was a new world.
But other than that,
other than those spots
in what we may have
called the old new world
or the new old world, for the
Jews, Jewish peddlers went
to no fewer places
than the Americas --
north, south, central,
as well as the Caribbean,
Southern Africa, and
Australia and New Zealand.
All over that new world, part
of the colonial expansion
of Europe, drew Jewish peddlers.
The activities of the
peddlers cleared the ground
for the eventual formation
of settled Jewish
communities in many places.
In other places, the
peddlers did not stay
but moved on elsewhere.
So, again, I'm going to throw
out a series of questions or --
that will form in a way
almost the bulk of the talk.
So, first, what did they sell?
Okay. Notably, it didn't
matter if I'm thinking about --
and I have documentation
about a Jewish --
a Lithuanian Jew who shows
up in Sweden or one who shows
up in the Cape Colony in what
will become South Africa,
if they show up in Mississippi
or in the Pacific Northwest
in Jamaica, in the
Irish Midlands.
They sold goods that we would
say were not necessities.
They didn't sell food,
they didn't sell fuel.
Because really those are the
two things one needs to survive.
But they sold a class of goods
that one historian
has called popu-lux.
Popular luxuries.
Now, they're goods that we
would not consider luxuries,
like eyeglasses, needles,
threads, mirrors, pictures
and picture frames to put up on
the wall, bed linens, towels,
napkins, tablecloths, okay?
So these were goods
that theoretically one
could live without.
One doesn't need to have
pictures on your wall
or you don't need to have a
mirror or even eyeglasses,
although every time I read about
a peddler selling eyeglasses
and the customer would say,
"This is the first
time I've had glasses."
I thought for me, my God, I'd
be paralyzed without my glasses.
These are people who are
entering into a new economic
and social mode and having
glasses was something
that opened up their eyes.
Okay. There's a wonderful
memoir by a man
who became the president
of Colombia South America.
And he had grown up in a
small town and he said,
"Until the Jewish peddlers
came into our town,
no peasant in this town
ever owned a pair of shoes."
Okay. And, again, one
can say a bit, I think,
maybe imaginatively, the world
felt literally different having
those shoes for the first time.
What is notable is that the
peddlers sold goods to women.
Their customers were all women.
The men were off working.
The peddler comes
during the day.
He established a business
connection with the wives
of farmers, miners, loggers,
mail workers, suburbanites,
steel workers, Native people
on -- living on reservations,
the workers in sugar cane
plantations, rubber plantations,
on American slave plantations,
American cotton plantations
and tobacco plantations.
The peddler established the
relationship with the women
as they sold the kind of goods
that were within women's domain.
So one of the very poignant
sort of details that emerged is
that in places like Cuba,
in Jamaica, and elsewhere
in Central America, the
peddlers sold neckties
and cloth handkerchiefs
to the wives
of sugar cane plantation
workers.
And while they leave us
very little information
about what went on between
customer and peddler,
one can get the sense
that for that woman
to buy her husband the
necktie or suspenders meant
that her husband on, let's
say Sunday, when they went
to church, could look good.
He didn't look like
a plantation worker.
He was going to now have a
tie and a cloth handkerchief
in his pocket and look no
poorer, no less subservient
than possibly the owner of
the sugar cane plantation.
So wherever the peddlers went,
they sold this category
of goods.
Most of them began by being
pack peddlers with packs
on their backs and
their first purchase
with some saved money was to get
a cart, okay, possibly bought
or rented with some
kind of draft animal,
depending on what animals were
being used in that region.
And then the peddler could carry
larger goods, perhaps stoves
or other kinds of items
for the home furniture
so that it expanded
what he could sell.
Interestingly, in
many places, peddlers,
once they had their wagon, began
carrying photographic equipment.
And so when they would come
into a home, they'd say,
"Would you like to have a
portrait -- a picture taken?"
Now, again, we could see
this leap into luxury
for a poor family to think that,
yes, let's have a photograph
of all of us to put
up on our wall.
As part of this move
upward to having a wagon
with a draft animal,
many of the peddlers,
as they made their route,
entered into business
relationships with the women
to whom they sold, and
created a connection
where the woman would bond --
during the week, and I'm going
to turn to the -- kind of
the calendrical pattern here.
During the week, the
woman would spend some
of her time collecting feathers,
bones, scraps of paper,
scraps of leather, fabric
that had been thrown out.
Sometimes they collected herbs.
And they would then
exchange these to the peddler
when he came back, often in
exchange for a certain amount
of feathers, okay, or bones
in exchange for a watch
or a necklace or some
other -- a broach.
Some other kind of a piece
of jewelry or whatever good
that the woman might want.
Okay. The peddler
would then sell the --
what was essentially refuse,
okay, to manufacturers
who would buy the old bones
to grind up for fertilizer
or for -- use it
to make buttons.
The feathers might
be used by somebody
who was going to
make mattresses.
The old scraps of paper
could be used for beating
down into some kind
of other good.
We might call them kind
of early recyclers, okay,
which is not what
they were called.
Not surprisingly, many peddlers
around the United States,
as well as elsewhere
in the world,
when they ceased peddling,
became the owners
of junkyards, okay?
Of scrap metal yards
because they had already been
in this business.
So this is what they sold.
I've already indicated that
they tended to sell to farmers,
to suburbanites, to textile
mill workers, miners, loggers.
They -- many peddlers
got the license to go
onto the Indian reservations
in the American west.
And these were usually
people who had limited money,
who had no access to stores
and to the marketplace.
So the peddler came to
where the customers were.
The peddlers, wherever
they went,
sold on a -- the
installment plan.
So I don't know, maybe my
glasses would be a dollar.
Okay. Probably not.
At least these weren't.
And so the customer might
pay a nickel, five cents.
And then he would come
back, however many weeks,
to collect on the rest
that was owed with the hope
that each time he came, she
might look in his bag and say,
"Oh, I see now you're also
carrying eight watches.
I could use one of those also."
Or, "I'd like my husband
to have one also."
So selling on the installment
plan not only helped the
customer, because the
customer was relatively poor,
but it also helped the peddler
because it expanded the number
of weeks to which he
would go to that home.
Peddlers had a specific
route, okay?
And the route was given to
them by their wholesaler
or their retailer, the
person who outfitted them,
who was almost always
-- I would --
in fact, maybe I would
take out the word almost.
Who was always another
Jew who was a shopkeeper
or who owned a peddler
warehouse or who owned some kind
of business stationary
enterprise that wholesaler,
retailer outfitter of the
peddler gave new immigrants,
because it's only Jewish --
it's only immigrants in
this Jewish population
who are peddling, would
give him the first bundle
of goods interest free.
I mean, this is a Jewish --
traditional Jewish obligation
of [inaudible] the loan
has to be interest-free.
And then every week, the
peddler would come back to --
for the weekend, the Sabbath.
Although if I call it, say
they came back for the Sabbath,
it implies they came back to
engage in religious activities,
which maybe they didn't.
Some did. Some didn't.
But Saturday night around
the peddler's world,
the peddler came
to the wholesaler,
paid him that which was due to
him, loaded up with a new bundle
of goods and then Sunday morning
went back out on the road again.
So this weekly cycle was built
into the lives of the peddlers.
In England, they were often
referred to among themselves
as Wochers, okay,
using the Yiddish word
or German word of woche, a week.
In Ireland, they were
called weekly men,
and in Irish materials, the --
whoever the memoirist or
whatever, the newspaper,
would [inaudible] weekly men.
The weekly man was here.
Okay. In parts of South
America, we had evidence
that they were referred
to as semananics.
So there you have the
semana, the Spanish for week,
and then the nic as a
kind of Yiddish sort
of suffix to the word.
So peddlers worked with the --
or they began with the
wholesaler, the supplier,
a supplier who was
the shopkeeper
in a town or in a large city.
Okay. He may be the owner
of a peddler warehouse.
Had numerous peddlers more --
numerous peddlers
working for him.
And each peddler
was giving a route.
Okay. And they in fact
referred to the route
as their medina,
okay, their state.
Okay. Peddlers could not
compete with each other.
They could not encroach
on each other's medina.
Why? Because the wholesaler
didn't want competition among
the peddlers, but rather
the more peddlers who worked
from this shop or that
shop, this warehouse
or that warehouse, the more
the wholesaler made a profit.
So the weekly cycle,
the connection to a node
of Jewish life, from which
the peddler got his goods,
and to which he returned
at the end of the week.
Now, so this is again how they
sold, this is what they sold,
this is how they
got their goods,
but the obvious middle
part of this is --
oh, let me actually
add one other thing.
The -- particularly for
the brand new immigrant
who didn't know Swedish
or English, Ute or French,
many in Quebec, or whatever
other language was the dominant
language, the wholesaler,
who's now somebody who's been
in the destination land for
five years, 10 years, whatever,
would give the new peddler a
piece of paper, a crib sheet
like we all used in high school
when we were studying
some foreign language.
We kept it under our notebook so
we could get through the test.
Written out in Yiddish
characters or for the peddlers
from the Balkans, many of
whom go to South America
in particular, he
would write out in --
let's make an English -- going
to an English-speaking land,
in Yiddish characters
or Hebrew characters,
"Good morning, ma'am.
How are you?
Would you like to
look in my bag?"
Okay. And then over the course
of weeks, months, years,
the peddler had no choice but to
develop his linguistic skills.
Many of them peddled in places
where there were multiple
languages being spoken,
so the peddler in parts
of Quebec were selling
to English speakers and
French speakers, okay?
Peddlers, almost all of
them came from Lithuania,
who went to Southern
Africa, who were selling
to English speakers,
Afrikaan speakers,
as well as the speakers of
the various African languages
that were spoken by the people
who had preceded either the
English or the Afrikaaner
so that the crib sheet
might have three languages
or five languages.
Okay. Now, I think one
of the interesting
phenomenon involved here is
that many Jews came from places
where they had always had
to have some level
of polylingualism
because they may have sold to
Lithuanians, to Polish speakers,
to German speakers, and while
one might be hard pressed
to say they actually spoke
Lithuanian or spoke Polish,
they knew enough
to buy and sell.
And so this was not a great
leap to move from that
to learning English,
Spanish, and Navajo, okay,
or whatever combination
of languages were required
in that particular medina
to which the peddler went.
So from the peddler's point
of view, this was a great way
to get started in a new land.
It may have been a great way
but it was also very difficult.
And I'm just going to read
you one quote and this is
from a man named Abraham
Cohn who came from Bavaria
in the 1840s, and he
fortunately left us a diary.
And he wrote very eloquently --
almost too eloquent to read this
since it's not a poetry reading.
"Beware oh youth of Bavaria
for you shall rue the hour
you embarked for this country
and a life far different
what you dreamed of.
This land -- " and he was
in western Massachusetts.
"This land and particularly
this calling,
being a peddler offers harsh,
cold air, great masses of snow,
cold towards foreigners
and to all
who do not speak the
language perfectly."
Okay. Again, this could have
been a young Lithuanian man
going through, traipsing around
the transmal or a Hungarian Jew
in the Australian outback.
The descriptions we have of
the misery, the heat, the cold,
the snow, the burning
sun, the muck, the mud,
was a universal trope.
I should also say that peddlers
were robbed left and right
because they were men on the
road with money and goods.
And I saw no evidence of
them ever arming themselves.
There were some peddler murders
and there were enough that --
that's actually one of
my best paper trails,
where when peddlers
were murdered
and the state then
came in to investigate.
So then I could find out in
my research who were they,
where were they from,
what goods did they carry,
how did their customers
feel about them,
who were their suppliers
and the like.
So so far, this is --
everything I've said has been
about the peddlers.
But the important link in the
story between the peddlers
and the suppliers are
the customers, okay?
The women whose homes,
the peddler --
whose threshold the peddler
crossed in order to sell.
And from all accounts, and as
you could imagine there's body.
There's nothing consistent about
where one can get reactions
of the customers to
the peddlers, they --
it seems to have been an
extremely positive encounter
for women living
in remote places,
for women who couldn't
get credit in stores,
who couldn't get to the stores.
The idea of this man
coming into their home
and offering them the eyeglasses
or the shoes or the neckties
or the picture frames was
an absolutely wonderful way
to enhance their own lives,
to announce their status
as somebody who could
afford to have eyeglasses
or picture frames or
tablecloths and the like.
Some memoirs give us evidence
of very positive exchanges
between peddlers and customers.
So one of my very
favorites was a book
by an African-American
social worker
and dietician named
J. Ida Jiggetts.
And she grew up in a small
town in the south and she said,
"The best day of the week was
when the Jewish peddler came
to our home and he would take
wonderous things out of his bag
and explain to us where
these goods came from."
And her father happened
to have been a minister
and seemingly he was home
when the peddler came.
It was not just selling
to the -- to his wife.
But the father, J.
Ida Jiggetts' father,
entered into an arrangement
with the peddler.
"I'll buy something but you
have to teach me a Hebrew word."
Okay. So that she went on to
say the day he came, he --
or when he came, he
reminded us of Santa Claus
because who else comes
bearing gifts into your home.
The peddlers, because I've
already told you had this weekly
cycle, the obvious question
was, well, where did they sleep
and where did they eat?
Okay. So the peddlers for the
most part slept in the home
of the last customer of the day.
They talked about
arranging their medina
so that the last customer
was the nicest, okay?
And that the person
would give them a bed,
not make them sleep in the barn.
Might give them a place
in front of the fireplace
because it was freezing
cold out.
And rather than send them
off into the elements to have
to sleep on the ground.
So they slept in their
customers' homes,
which then opens up for --
opened up for them and for the
customers and for us a kind
of universe of meaning and
thinking about the integration
of immigrants into --
a particular kind of
immigrant into a new place.
So first issue, okay, the
Jewish peddler comes into a home
in Arkansas, in New Mexico,
in Southern Africa, in Cuba,
in Sweden, okay, wherever.
And that very nice
customer who at the end
of the day invites them
to sleep over, says,
"Yes, you can sleep here."
She says, "Would you
like to eat with us?"
How very kind of
perhaps venal question.
"Would you like to eat with us?"
Although maybe not so
venal because I'm sure
if somebody knocked on my door
and said, "Can I sleep here?
Would you like -- can I come
in and sell you something
and by the way, can
I sleep over?"
Obviously, the answer is I
wouldn't have opened the door
in the first place.
But, "Would you like
to eat with us?"
Now, perhaps it's a very
ordinary question except these
were immigrant Jewish men
for whom the problem
of food loomed large.
That is, can they eat?
Should they eat?
Might they eat?
The pork, squirrel, bear,
whatever people were eating
and considered tasty
and nutritious
and was just the ordinary
fare of ordinary life.
So we have, again,
in very spotty ways,
narratives that span the,
"I was so hungry I would
have eaten anything.
I didn't care what it was."
And it was -- actually,
it tasted pretty good.
And who were not
troubled while on the road
about the Jewish dietary laws.
And others who would
say to this woman
who now has opened her house to
him, "I cannot eat your food."
Which, from her point of view,
had to raise the most obvious
question of, "Why not?"
Okay. Now, these are all places
where there are no Jews, okay?
These are the only Jews who
come into these communities
and into these people's lives.
So the peddlers, again, in the
evidence we have, would say,
"My religion does not
allow me to eat that."
"Well, what religion are you?"
I mean, the person
might know Catholic,
they might know Methodist,
they might know Presbyterian.
They might know -- but what --
which of those religions
say you can't eat something?
And so, "I'm Jewish.
I'm of the Hebrew faith."
Whatever the formulation.
And, on the one hand, this seems
like it would have
been a barrier,
a kind of the door comes down,
"Well, then get out of here."
But to the contrary in, again,
the material that is available
to researchers, in most cases,
the woman says, "What
can you eat?
If you can't eat the
meat, what can you eat?"
"Bread, fruit, vegetables."
Sometimes peddlers would
actually leave a pot in the home
of the -- in the
customer's home,
so every Monday his pot
would be in one person's home
and another pot in
another person's home.
Or he carried a pot with him and
he either prepared his own food
or she would make what he
told her was acceptable.
So this -- and we have
beyond the food issue,
although I think the
food issue was so crucial
and the most formative part of
this, but many of the peddlers
in their sporadic narratives
talked about or recalled waking
up early in the morning in
the customer's home and going
and praying by himself
in a corner,
putting on his prayer
shawl, putting on his --
to fill in the leather boxes
with straps for the forehead
and for the arm and for the
customer, "Well, what is this?
I've never seen it before."
Okay. These are not people
who had taken comparative
religion 101.
And, again, the peddler
is required,
required because he
wants to make a sale.
He is not required
because he wants
to foster interfaith
understanding.
He wants to make a sale.
He explains, "This
is how Jews pray."
The next few stories I'm going
to tell you come from memoirs,
and generally as a historian,
I'm extremely suspicious
of memoirs.
Okay. Why?
Because how people remember and
how they want their children
and grandchildren to remember
can be somewhat embellished.
But I've seen the following
couple stories in a number
of places that I'm
going to take it
as at least potentially
accurate.
And since I have no way
of checking up, okay,
we'll have to listen
to their words.
And the words, even if
they're embellished,
still offer us a window
into the peddler experience.
So one man talked about
putting on his tefillin
with the long leather straps
and at that moment, the --
somebody from the
family came into the room
where he was donning his
phylacteries and she screams.
Okay. "Mr. Goldberg is trying
to commit suicide
by hanging himself."
Okay. And he had
to explain, "No.
This is part of Jewish prayer."
Likewise, in stories that
come out of the American south
in both white and
African American homes,
as well as in the
Midwest in South Africa,
in places particularly
where Protestantism was
the dominant faith and in
which there was a great emphasis
on the family Bible reading,
according to these narratives,
the man of the home --
he's now in charge -- the wife
buys the stuff but the man
of the home is in charge of
the family Bible reading --
would hand the Bible
to the peddler and say,
"Since you are one of the
Hebrews or you are one
of the chosen people, will
you read the Bible for us."
Okay. And indeed my
absolutely favorite story,
and I do hope it's true,
but it comes from a memoir
which a daughter wrote down
about her father's life.
He was a Lithuanian
Jewish peddler
who peddled in the Dakotas.
And his customers knew him
to be an extremely pious man.
So pious, his name
was Moshe, Moses.
So religious that they
called him Holy Moses.
And in one particular
swing around the week
in this primarily German
population in the Dakotas,
several customers approached
him and said, "Moses,
we have a favor to ask you."
So what was the favor?
Said, "Our minister
died and it's going
to be months -- I
mean, it's winter.
It's going to be
months until the church,
the synod in Minneapolis
will send us a new preacher.
You are such a religious man.
Would you come and
lead services for us
until we get a new minister?"
So as his daughter wrote
down and as he recalled,
for several months on Sunday
morning, Holy Moses went
to this local German
speaking church.
Now, he didn't lead them
in prayers that he left
for them to do for themselves.
But she said he led them
every week in a exposition
of the weekly Torah reading,
the Parshat ha-Shavua.
And now he spoke -- because
he came from Lithuania,
he was a Yiddish speaker and he
also had a smattering of German
that he was able to
communicate with them.
And as the daughter recalled,
he was so proud of the fact
that he taught them about Rashi,
as this medieval Jewish
commentator who, as a young man
in Lithuania, Holy Moses would
have studied in whatever level.
Wherever the peddlers went, they
were in search of one thing only
and it wasn't brotherhood.
It wasn't religious
kind of fraternity
with people who were different.
It was, they wanted
to sell something.
And so one of the issues
that becomes very significant
in the study of Jewish peddlers
in the American south is
that they sold willy-nilly
to white families,
to African American families.
Okay. It didn't matter to
them who the customer was,
what the local morays
were, a woman,
an African American woman had as
much ability to buy eyeglasses
or needles and thread
as a white woman.
One commentator, one
observer of the time said
that the Jewish peddler was
the only white man who came
into African American homes who
doffed his hat to the woman,
bowed to her, all right, in
tremendous respect and tried
to proceed with having her be
enticed by something in his bag.
Notably, he was probably the
only white person whom she could
throw out if she wanted.
He was a stranger,
he was an immigrant.
He had no authority behind him.
He was not the representative
of the landowner,
he was not the representative
of the state.
He was just an immigrant
trying to sell something.
So I want to end with one
more part of this story,
and I hope you all
have some questions.
Wherever they went, Sweden
and Ireland, Southern Africa
and Australia, Cuba, Jamaica,
Haiti, Mississippi, Missouri,
Kansas, Oregon, the peddlers,
however much the women like them
and enjoyed having the -- this
person come into their home
and sell them something,
they raised the ire
of the local shopkeepers.
The local shopkeepers
hated them, okay?
So the peddler could
come into a woman's home.
He could flatter her.
"Oh, your daughter looks
so beautiful today.
What a beautiful
table you have."
He could make her feel good
and he could sell for less
because he had no overhead.
He didn't have a
store that he --
property or that he had
to either pay mortgage
or pay a rent for.
And the women seemed
to prefer the peddler
over the local shopkeepers
for all sorts of reasons.
And so the local
shopkeepers engaged
in political activity
all over the world to try
to push out the peddlers.
Okay? Sometimes it was by trying
to get their representatives,
the local city council, the
local state legislature,
even in the parliament, to raise
the taxes or to raise the fee
for a peddler's license.
Okay. Making it prohibitive.
Okay. The state of North
Carolina tried to pass a law
that said only citizens
could get peddler's licenses.
Well, that was certainly not in
the interests of the peddlers
because they were all
immigrants and by definition,
they weren't citizens yet.
Some places, peddler local
merchant antagonism sparked
into violence, okay,
and there were acts
of violence perpetrated
against the peddlers.
In some places, laws
were introduced
to actually expel them.
One representative to the
parliament in the Cape Colony
of Southern Africa, in an
inquest on the peddlers said,
"As far as I'm concerned,
the only thing we should do
with these Jewish
peddlers is expel them.
But our wives and daughters
would never put up with that."
So we have their story and their
story ends, as does my talk,
with the fact for none of
them, as far as I can tell,
because the numbers are elusive,
but for I'm going to say none
of them was this a
lifetime occupation.
It was two years, three
years, four years.
Some of them became
so fabulously wealthy
that their names are emblazoned
in our public culture.
The late lamented
Lehman Brothers, okay?
Well, that's how Mayer
Lehman got his start.
Or Guggenheim, Rosenwalds.
So Julius Rosenwald's
father came as a peddler,
as did his maternal
uncles, Gimbels.
Okay. And on and on and on.
Very few of them became
Lehman or Guggenheim
or Rosenwald or Gimbels.
That is a very unusual
and atypical story.
Most became the owners of
small stores in back --
in small towns or
they became the owners
of stores in larger cities.
They might go open a peddler
warehouse, a junkyard.
Some kind of a business venture.
But they did not remain for
a lifetime behind that horse
or on the road, and for
sure their sons did not get
up on the wagon and get
behind their father's horses.
So in some, these men whose --
most of whose names
we do not know,
most of whom were not
great political actors,
they were not great intellects,
they were not famous
political activists.
However, I want to content,
had as much role in the making
of the modern Jewish experience
as did the political people,
the great activists,
the writers,
the scholars, and
the famous ones.
And by just picking up that
pack and taking the road,
they transformed not only
Jewish history but the history
of the places to
which they went.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Okay. Could I trouble
you to open this?
I had a little encounter
with a knife and an eggplant.
Yeah. So I just had -- I'm
going to take your questions.
I will repeat them
but I just wanted
to explain I can't open
my own water bottle.
Okay. I'm just fine.
Yes, sir.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Okay. So the question was,
did the peddlers keep
their own records
and what kind of
sources did I use?
So some of them did and you can
imagine for most of these men,
by the time they finished
peddling, their 18 months
or their 36 months or
whatever of peddling,
and they had their little pieces
of paper, they threw them out.
Okay. What was more
important was the store
that they were going to have.
But there's some in
scattered places.
And -- if you can read them
because they're almost
incomprehensible.
But what's important about their
record keeping is they were
essentially independent
entrepreneurs.
They were not like
the Fuller Brush Man
or the Singer Sewing Machine,
you know, the traveling salesman
who worked for a corporation
who gave the traveling salesman
a record book and a standard way
to record sales,
expenses, and somebody
in the home office would
go through their books.
These guys worked
for themselves,
and while they had a wholesaler,
they could pick up other kinds
of goods as they wanted and
that was not the business
of their wholesaler.
So the fact even that they kept
the records themselves tells us
something about them
and their independence.
So what did I use?
So picture a -- one of
those all-you-can-eat places
and you'll say, "I can take a
little this and then a little
of that and all the -- " I
mean, there's no one source.
I would say this was a book
that could not have been written
without the internet and
those vast search engines
like the [inaudible] Trust.
And when I plugged in the word
Jewish peddler, I got millions
of hits and was obviously
unable to read them all
to take advantage of them all,
but I'll just give
you a smattering.
They show up in Jewish
communal histories.
They show up in local
Jewish newspapers or even
in global Jewish newspapers.
So like the Jewish Chronicle
of England, you know,
published in London, had
little articles all the time
about a Jewish peddler was
just murdered in the big --
you know, in the South
Island of New Zealand.
So that and then where
it seemed to be useful,
I would then try
to track it down.
Where there were controversies
between Jewish peddlers
and local shopkeepers,
those were fantastic,
because somebody came
in to investigate
and here I'll just mention
that in the first decade
of the 20th century, there
was a two-year boycott
of the Jewish peddlers
in Limerick, Ireland.
Okay. Organized by a
local priest at the urging
of the local Irish
Catholic shopkeepers.
So the local newspapers
are writing about this.
Somebody -- investigators come
from the board of delegates
of deputies of British
jury to come in to try
to patch over the controversy.
Those left paper trails, and
so again, you get to find
out what they were selling.
And so the record books
of R.G. Dun, okay,
which are at the Baker Library
at Harvard, where the --
these were investigations by
anonymous agents who wrote
about the credit worthiness
of local businessmen.
So they're organized
by state, by year.
I mean, it's -- they're
voluminous.
And I only picked Maine
and South Carolina, okay?
And in fact I ended up with
South Carolina only picking one
or two counties.
And, fortunately, the
investigators for Dun happened
to have a thing about Jews
and so they'd write Jewish,
you know, which was great.
I mean, he may have
been terrible to be
so essentializing,
but then I got
to seeing what was
being said about them.
And so the investigators
for R.G. Dun would write,
so and so store,
former Jewish peddler,
used to peddle, Jew,
used to peddle.
Customers say he is hardworking
sober industrious and trust him.
Okay. So that was a source.
When there were murders,
okay, inquests, biographies,
autobiographies, the works
of local Jewish historical
societies
where they did oral
history projects.
So like that all-you-can-eat
place, I couldn't go
to all the archives to
see all the memoirs,
but I tried to sample as
much of them as possible.
And what I ended up
getting was, I think,
a pretty accurate story.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Sure. So that's a
great question.
So, yes, I mean, it was in that
area because they could only go
so far because they
had a weekly cycle.
So if Saturday night they
loaded up their wagons or loaded
up their backpack,
how far could they get
from where that store was?
Now, as new transportation
technology came in,
they might take a train an
hour away and then peddle
and come back on the train.
Or they might take a canal
boat, a boat on a canal,
or some other conveyance.
But it was relatively
routed in a particular area,
southwestern Missouri
or upstate New York.
And the route was as large as
they could walk or go by horse.
So Isaac Mayer Wise, the kind of
founder of the reform movement
and reform Judaism in America,
wrote a lot about peddlers.
That's, again, another place
where people observed
what they were doing.
And he said the typical
peddler started
with a pack of over 100 pounds.
Okay. Now, I know when
I buy groceries and it's
about 10 pounds, I
get it delivered.
So how far can one get
carrying that on one's back?
So it was a relatively
small circuit.
Once they had a horse and wagon,
obviously they would negotiate
with the wholesaler to give
them a bigger territory.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Yeah. I mean, I would say they
were definitely a transmission
agent of current events
in that they had just been
in the larger town and they're
going to this isolated area.
And they said, "Oh, you
know what happened."
But they were -- they tried
to steer very far away
from politics because
you never know.
You want to sell something
and the last thing you want
to do is offend somebody.
I didn't see books and
I didn't see newspapers.
And -- but it's very
interesting.
The word for peddler in
Hebrew is [inaudible]
which means gossip.
And so yeah.
So and the best gossip was,
"Your neighbor just
bought a tablecloth.
Don't you want one too?"
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Okay. So that's a great --
so the question -- I'm sorry.
I was supposed to
repeat the questions.
So who produced the goods
and did their wives
perhaps produce some
of the maybe crafts
that they sold?
Certainly, there were cases,
but what's important is the
goods were brought to them
through these peddler warehouses
which were often connected
to Jewish manufacturers, okay,
in the very large cities.
So there'd be a Jewish
manufacturer
in New York who's
making, you know, mirrors.
Okay. And the wholesaler
might make four trips a year
from Talladega to New
York to get to buy goods.
Okay? And so he had his Jewish
contacts with whom he --
from whom he got goods.
The Jewish peddlers in Ireland
were getting their goods
from Jewish manufacturers
in England or from Jewish --
they -- in Ireland, there
was a lot of picture frame
and picture frame making, and
the picture frames were all made
by former peddlers in -- living
in Dublin, Limerick, and Cork,
who went into picture
frame making.
And then the peddlers would
go out in the countryside
with the picture
frames and usually
with Catholic, religious
pictures.
You know, Bleeding
Heat of Jesus, Mary,
the Last Supper, and so on.
Now, the other part
of the question,
which is something
I didn't touch on,
but it's really important,
and you mentioned their wives.
So here the question is, are
these married men or not?
And so some of the
men were single, okay,
and there is a whole story
from all over the world
where these single Jewish
peddlers meet local women
who are just not Jewish and end
up in relationships, both legal
and just common, but
often for lifetime.
Some of the peddlers,
particularly towards the end
of the 19th century, from places
like Lithuania and so on --
oh, and let me go back.
The ones who are unmarried,
they find Jewish --
those who don't marry
local women will marry
when they stop peddling.
So opening a store
in Tupper Lake,
New York means now I'm
going to get married.
And sometimes they go back
home to the community in Posen
or Bavaria or wherever, and
they'll find a young woman
and marry her and
bring her over.
Sometimes, the local -- whatever
is the closest local Jewish
community will have
the daughters of.
Okay. So I mentioned
Julius Rosenwald.
His father was a peddler.
His outfitter, the
Baltimore-based outfitter
for Samuel Rosenwald, who
himself had been a peddler,
had -- you know, there
were four brothers.
Their name was the Hammer
[inaudible] Brothers
and they had one sister.
Okay. Well, when Samuel
Rosenwald was ready
to settle down, he married
the sister of his creditors.
Some of the peddlers left
wives and children back
in the old home -- Europe, or
in the Balkans or other parts
of the Ottoman Empire.
And when they could settle
down, when they were going
to stop peddling, they'd
then call for the wife
and children to join them.
And some of them left
their wives and children
in a big city, let's say in
New York, but then they went
to peddle in the Adirondacks and
might see the wife and the rest
of the family at Passover
or at the holiday,
you know, in the fall holidays.
So this whole connection
between peddling
and marital patterns was very --
was really central
to this history.
Yes, sir, in the back.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Okay. So was there a genre of
manuals for dealing with how
to observe the holidays and
the Sabbath and Kashrut?
Manuals, no, but other
kinds of sources.
And what I think is really
notable in this concept
of new world Jewish
peddling -- and, by the way,
there are such manuals
in Europe,
for Jewish peddlers in Europe.
But here, the men are pretty
much improvising on their own.
"I will, I won't, I'm
going to eat the food,
I'm not going to eat the food.
I'm going to only
eat the food if."
Okay? And I see a
direct connection
between this improvisation and
kind of trying to figure it
out on their own
without rabbinic
or authoritative sources.
And the creation of a new kind
of Judaism in the new world,
particularly in America, which
gave much greater license
to ordinary people to decide
what they want to do and how.
And rabbis in the big cities
writing for, you know,
the [inaudible] or some of the
other Jewish newspapers coming
out of New York or
Philadelphia thought
that peddling was horrible.
They thought, this is terrible
because it's leading to exactly
that individual choice
in determining, you know,
how to observe the law.
And they wanted to get
Jews out of peddling.
And the peddling
continued to be attractive
until it was just
economically no longer the mode
by which people -- ordinary
people got their stuff.
Yes, sir?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Okay. So the question was did
I find competing wholesalers?
Yes. In the same
[inaudible] absolutely.
Okay? There'd be two, three,
four peddler warehouses.
And so they all want to
make a kind of sweet deal
with the peddler because
they need the peddlers
because that's how they're
going to get their goods out.
And so they have to offer
the peddler good rates
for the goods, favorable
rates on the goods, good --
the kind of goods that the
peddler says the customer wants.
Lot of people, there
are lots of fights.
Not necessarily physical
fights but anger.
You know, kind of people take
offense and peddler will switch
from one wholesaler to another.
Many of the peddlers,
once they finish,
set up their own
wholesale enterprises.
So essentially they're competing
with their old wholesalers.
So, yeah, there was a
great deal of competition.
So those folks could be
competing with each other
but the peddlers could not
compete with other peddlers.
[Inaudible] my pleasure.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.